all right I'm good
and finally holy crap guys we're alive
it's mostly my fault I was completely
unaware that the world of discord screen
sharing and getting audio through that
was gonna be bananas but all of that
attempts aside we are gonna do it a
different way so basically what we have
is the for a second reveal stream I
recorded it I got it up so we're both
just gonna watch it at the same time and
then if either of us just says pause
we're gonna hit pause on our computer
and go from there so we're gonna watch
it watch it old school really crappy as
we're gonna try and do this mostly
because we have avoided as many spoilers
as we can now like even just like
talking to each other on Twitter for a
second we each probably saw a glimpse of
something mm-hmm
YouTube is already out there people like
wow so we just want to get there don't
you guys to be a part of it let me give
some clarity to like this is gonna be
like again raw reactions both of us have
dodged spoilers like the plague we have
not seen anything on this thing so again
this will be our live reactions with it
and again I'm not gonna let eat eat
boxes take all you know we both have
some technical difficulties but we are
here we're ready for forsaken the reveal
that is this gonna save it we're gonna
see man we're gonna find out so alright
guys so one little caveat I do believe
there is a vital key in the front of
this just because that's literally what
went live on Twitter like as soon as the
stream started but at any point you want
to pause it we hit and pause so I just
want to make sure stream is live cool
I'm good on my end yeah I'm good on my
end I just wanna see if I can get your
chat up as well so I can watch both it
you are alive
those are beets hey what's up saying
what I mean make sure are you're good on
your hangouts I don't have enough means
right chat in there you got yourself
covered okay alright guys so without too
much further ado cuz we're already here
mm-hm all right in three we're at 59
seconds so three two one go
all right I'm moving baby I'm moving so
50 to 150 you pretty close yeah I'm
close I'm at 49 48 47 26 yeah you're
like a hero I'll pause mine for a sec
hold on
mm-hmm don't me to pause to mid 36 like
we're good now I got you covered
nice thank you bro Oh so guys we are we
are hyped we are possibly have no idea
what's Kyra's work what up everyone else
knows what's out there and we have no
idea so yes yep don't you dance were
laughs yeah sorry I love that music man
avoid that's the only thing that's the
best part of your sorrows DLC is the
music oh well yeah I'll give you that
all right and we going here we go a lot
of pressure on this DLC man no kidding
here we go whoo I like the logo mm-hmm
good oh I don't know falling yeah crazy
it's gay Kaede yep
Kirk Kirk Oh what is that
mmm-hmm narrative leaves yep oh yeah
what is that I have no idea that verax
looks like it Oh hold on pause that
pause that I'm paused I met a number six
23 division yes hold on I'll go up to
630 but okay where are you paused 623
okay either way yeah they're followed
but they don't even remotely look the
same
yeah they're crazy man this this look
like some white pirates to the deep like
this like in the prison and we do know
that a was a Kade is putting people in
the prison for my understanding yeah
I've heard something like that I don't
even know so on screen you're looking at
yeah same thing I am so we've got you
are 6:23 yeah I moved Sarah oh cool
thanks Wow
yeah looks like you got fall on the
right some crazy fire thing this dude
looks like he's covered in blue
electricity maybe that's the prison
piece there like escorting something but
it looks like a mini ogre I don't know
what they're escorting yeah I don't know
this is crazy
alright you ready to go back to this
yeah
three two one go go that's disscourn
mmm
that's cool okay those are definitely
are different models in the big boys yep
uh hold pause that pause that damn it
I'm a seven oh six seven oh five they're
six okay so so we got three slot still
mm-hmm we got a different looking emblem
by the way 600 I called that by the way
because it's not a 600 it's not gonna be
big enough ability resilience recovery
you're still there anything I see here
kittens I don't see anything an energy
sled that's different no but yeah
something's different cuz you've got
like a 1 a 2 and a 3 kind of or a 1 and
a 3 it looks like cuz he's on energy
right now oh yeah and that's got a 2 on
the attack number if you're looking at
thin line there you are so level 50 got
what level are we right now 30 30
yeah that's 20 levels that's more than
they ever did before so lot to grind
we'll have to grind lot to grow 600 it's
gonna be some work yeah that's gonna be
some work but that's what we won so
honestly like if it was ever like a
World of Warcraft type situation you'd
literally dump everything you had and
start fresh but yeah everybody's too
afraid to doing that anyway alright so
weapons and stuff will continue I
already put this thing back up alright
let me know when you're ready 3 2 1 go
go sniper
Piper shotgun and one what one wall I
paused it at 7:12 go back to that if you
can scroll back to 712 snipe we're at
war now peep that no sniper into shotgun
in one house yeah yeah shotgun one must
have a little [ __ ] yes I'm 12
yeah yeah I'll go 711 again mine's
easier to move it's probably just a
bigger screen yeah oh you're just
looking at Hamrick right now look way
over go one over there we go okay
okay so yeah this whole one-two-three
thing is definitely something shotgun
still six rounds right I wonder if they
using like a point system to allocate
you know value so basically looks like
they give enough flexibility right
because you got a shotgun in one yeah
wells like is so you'll just have like
kinetic shotguns energy snipers you
might have stuff in different places but
you can use it just depends on what if
you can off like three shotguns which
would be useless but I mean if you have
the new for them but here's that they
know if they still be in it they still
holding on in the kinetic energy and
what you would assume that this
trackless waste shotgun can only be in
the kinetics but I don't know this is
interesting
yeah alright let's keep it going three
hundred to one
Coco Acker is still there there's a hand
cannon that's probably gonna be exotic
random rolls coming back yes Oh how's
that pause that really - oh yes 7:41 let
me see how a different that looks than
you'll go back to 721 cuz I see nothing
I sent for you actually
I'm 41 whatever that I seven 40s later
I'm looking at that that is I don't know
what that is that's heaven oh man
damn late
looks really ornate to be fault well
okay
one random sweat I think I have an idea
where this is coming from but yeah this
is really ornate but there's a place
where the awoken come from and we're
kind of going there to the next place
we'll get that okay
so whether it's just a beast so feel
free to color any pauses I feel like I'm
the only one doing it or you don't
because I'm more in like absorption mode
so yeah call out pause I'm not gonna
pause as much unless it's something that
really I'm like okay I can't even deal
with this right now
analytical absorption mode I'm just
sorry but hey random roles are back so
how long got that in there so it's huge
huge all right three two one go
nice so random rolls and the master work
system in combination
what are HAP Oh what the hell is that
hold on I'm sorry
okay that's large I'm sorry if what I
say fire tornado okay that is insane
pause wet ball you got the paws dirty
now we go hunt is doing that's crazy
we got to go that's my first cause I'm
putting it in
okay so scroll back when he say 29 bro
he's deflecting with the Ox tryna
awesome 31 but yeah yeah that is okay so
new supers or changes of a knife third
tree to also oh like variations of
existing supers or maybe like you said
maybe maybe I'm hoping they've expanded
the skill tree to present more options
like d1 no that well they desperately
need to do that so right because but
remember our major beast was that you
know we felt we were locked in the to
preset loadouts
per subclass right yeah we didn't have
that so maybe this is a hint back in
that direction whatever they say this is
far they're obviously not new subclasses
but then the extreme variations that
hammer with the Titan the arm there's a
fire tore the fighter tornado what then
then is like what was it the gunslinger
hunter was on throwing ninja stars like
he was like solar knives or something
like fire and that was again like golden
do you take so it's like you have a
class mm-hmm
how many supers do you think they have
new because I mean you have a 3-2
character or three characters
and what one main super how many more
supers I don't know no idea okay I have
no idea what's going on right now no I
will say this is very impressive
this is very pretty look can week when
we go back a bit yeah first debuted oil
as wildness give me a timestamp I got
I'll print um his dad this is crazy
so you have the exotics and the master
works they talked about and okay yeah
there's a flying Titan Superman bomb
[Laughter]
okay okay you want to go to 7:56 if you
can fix is what a fun start oh my
goodness I'm at 7:56 right now it's
blank screen but I'll tell me when it go
all right three two one go bro what
[Laughter]
fired knives no giant hammer that he
just likes he Oh fire tornado into the
Power Man that's what being a Guardians
about yeah I want to feel godlike
exactly - that's my you might want to be
a hundred reflecting your back whoa Oh
what to do oh I like warlock yo oh my
god get my steak ari have a heart and a
new weapon type what oh yeah I see you
fall into masteries we have ranged bows
bows so even though ox can use that yeah
oh yeah
[Laughter]
boom oh oh you let me see so this is
gambit yeah it's not me to do mold right
yeah yeah this is the new mode
it's what's 44
oh man silly party PvE slash PvP mode
but Kento that invader hit another pause
that my hair just pause it pause it
pause it pause five to ten fifty - I'm
at 52 - oh my what do you think that is
I mean it's so it's not quite halo five
what does it called war zone or
something
once alone that's what I was taking
right so much but you've got two
separators but if you can cross and
shoot the others mm-hmm
oh man as he like that yeah like he he
said you could invade in it was a PvP
PvE mix yeah so I mean if you think
about timing right so you have a blocker
you block their Bank say you send the
blocker and then say you've got a chance
to go over there they're trying to build
up their tokens and survive to get it
killed so they can you know just posit
their stuff you go over there
you're a stealth hunter you sword swipe
all and pick up other stuff a run back
and you just got a huge lead yeah that
crazy this is what this is what they
need this is something that will give
you a very different playing experience
and they desperately need - we need it
and this is what the community son of
guys were talking about you know they
well mode that they've never seen before
in destiny you know everyone for again
we've got tremendous sources he and
everyone that we trust was like this
mode is a game changer so this is gonna
be crazy just gonna be crazy shout out
the crystal elite in the chat everybody
Punk in the chat yeah it's this crazy
man no you ready alright three two one
go
that's exactly what ADEQ wants to hear
yep oh my woken what
[Music]
mmm huh you know it looks beautiful just
the scope the scenery whoa what you
heard that yep okay pause that for a sec
cause applause applause it okay by the
way that Titans William is amazing yeah
absolutely my TOEFL
what's up monkey much 12:11 only what
else Lee slow it up let's see what my
dip with day ones in it okay um but you
can say on this one so biggest like
seems like one of the biggest raids most
bosses they've ever had and right I'm
trying to think you hadn't grace the
sisters the sisters golgoroth
that's four that's already what I know
vault didn't have that now for is got to
be the biggest read a big had the most
bosses days days yeah so there's gonna
be at least five bosses which is not a
short encounter much less all the
puzzles of do you get I'm not getting I
don't want to get to guessed but I'm not
getting a late raid lair vibe but he did
say something about it evolving over
time he said for those over weeks of
weeks yeah he's like the first time you
guys step in it look different after
weeks he's like the people who go in and
raid are going to change the light
changed what is in there I guess or
changed a little so I don't think it's
like I don't think it's an in time live
destructive environment or anything like
that like battlefield but I think it'll
be like as like you know more times the
boss gets killed or something you know
happens over and over right everything's
gonna happen more frequently yeah I
don't think I don't think they could do
it I mean I don't picture a red layer
honestly I hope not cause it anyway yeah
no I liked it like this looks like a
fleshed-out world that's what I'm
talking about
you know that's where I'm at one okay
let me know when you're ready all right
one sec all right and three two one go
that's so sick
yes oh there you go
okay hmm holy crap hmm interesting take
Wow that's some from world yeah I wonder
how they're gonna show that in India
it looks crazy yeah gambit Oh what is
that what's that oh no you didn't know
you didn't there's no such thing as
going overboard
no those look insane crazy Oh hold on
pause it pause it
go back what you want to do 1310 relay
back at I'm a 1337 1313 38 I'm at 13 36
either way yeah by the way that sword
void swipe thing sound crazy yeah it's
just like wish and they just like
nothing biggest thing he said is Armour
perks right which is what I'm seeing
when I'm in the Dreaming city you'll
deal more damage old targets there we go
remember this well in the Dreaming City
you take more damage from all sources
that's like a give and take right there
mm-hmm okay oh yeah it is yeah because
you said well you could take more damage
yeah yeah that's very risk/reward that's
crazy
hmm interesting I want to I just wanted
to pause here's like Armour perks is
honestly one of the biggest things I I
need like right I need half my inventory
to matter it's like yeah you got a ghost
yeah you got three different slots now
you can mix it up how you want I still
want to know how that works but we'll
get there it sounds like but yeah yeah I
just want are look at the left you got
the one two three yep and it just seems
like kinetic energy power power hood
it's got its like grenade launcher
sniper and hand can't like I don't know
how you pick a token amount or is it
just like free slots and everything can
drop everywhere like outside of power
cuz I don't see something I don't get
the vibe that for example kinetic hand
cannon in the one slot like I don't get
a fight we can do right there might be
separates like you might have kinetic
sniper's energy sniper yeah I think new
weapons are gonna complete appear my gut
says again I'm just estimating there's
about 2000 things in the game how about
a big vault and arrow straight out of
warframe
hey I'll take it dig it yeah when you're
ready all right three two one go go
mmm what is what what is what's the hunt
is the flash now I don't
I'm low-key feeling the hunter this you
ain't go for all right just pause it
right here on that title all right I'm
at 1401
before to sit there with beads looking
straight at the camera what's up I'm not
a DJ metaphor Jail with the forsaken
logo oh wow so vitae
I will say like building up the hype I
think they manage that yeah I got that
going tight was good destiny game
doesn't need to game destiny two
expansions one and two require but
that's that's given you know minutes I
know how that go you have to buy
everything now will there be a bundle to
buy it all together I'm sure I'm sure
just they did they did before like what
was it destiny the collection same thing
I'm sure though I got a little warlock
Envy right now man they're huntin look
craziness you the Golden Gun class you
know whatever this that with the Stars
the damn Ark Strider is on some old
kungfu you can't he's doing that
Deadpool deflection I like like like
that is crazy it's crazy I still love
the Titans Superman bomb like that is
just like just don't see anything you
don't seem that were void like was he
put the hand out he did some like so
like like a blue laser comment RuPt in
out of the hand for them and then what
about the void the dodge dodge dodge not
blast that was the way that was that was
warm that was the Warlock that was a
sure I wasn't sure I don't know what the
solar is but that's the warlock doing
those dashes so
okay we got we got some options so I
don't know yeah those other two are
about to take over the other supers and
make them look like crap I hope they
like kind of the others so you know you
got either that or like I said my god is
gonna be that these are the new
variation trees per yeah something like
that
you say you ready to rock yeah yep three
two one guild oh sorry guys for all the
countdowns but it's how we got to do it
today I teach in the building
Scott I remember Scott razza very yeah
something like that yeah a beer
Ryan time yeah I remember him rise yep I
do remember
what is it that you do here Thank You
somebody needs their I can handle that
space Legolas
[Music]
yeah I was like how about don't tell me
anything at all just make it long
that looks nice
that looks kind of amazing
their art department team has always
been phenomenal yeah it's kind of off
the charts earlier
Hey
it's actually good thank you
I can get together yeah nice I don't
want them to tell too much it's my only
worry yeah
would be nice but probably not us
[Laughter]
yes can I play it now please no what's
now he's wearing that shirt yeah damn it
the new load redacted
[Laughter]
campus that's about as they can say yeah
lightly
the invasion sounds crazy that's the
part I want them to if they get it - I
don't know if they do it today
yes I'll be I'll be looking for that
yeah go capture yourself some of that
you already know if they allow it
yep the Lord's will be in the building
svet whoa damn oh I'm coming through
coming through baby
II
you know beta hmm Carter in con yep
bastards Oh doc how big would it be good
yeah I literally refunded my ticket but
I'll survive
I'll survive that's cool though that
they doing that with the community -
yeah that's sadly yeah you know
surprising that they January look like
the year we don't go on film yeah of
course yep let's destroy rate layers to
the ground
it sounds financial for things freedom
someone's going to what is this
mm-hmm so he's at 3:00 next dlcs
basically
I got jokes right now you oh I'm sure
you do yes please because all I'm seeing
it's priced of is if I hate yeah that
looks like a raid icon a great icon not
real a.m. just noticed that's the ace of
spades in the lower right you don't know
you want a spot pause it real quick yeah
go for it I matter 26:14 what is it 20
2014 I just noticed that was ace of
spades in the lower I hit corn I didn't
yeah because K is the one in the story
so he's tired mm-hmm you would you got
to say 26:14 running it 26:14 come on
computer stop fighting me did you find
you two okay for some reason I can't get
the 1413 deposit co-op see if I can will
attack okay no I got a so in game
challenges mmm
not content but challenges Rachael Ray
challenge modes that's the vibe I'm
getting
okay got one a chat monkey punch over
here punch what up he said make that
bleep free after you beep up Bungie yeah
it is a big there's a big thing in a
community right now which is because of
the debacle of Destiny tool at launch
that they have some nerve for charging
you know and yeah I mean listen in a
perfect world in a perfect world yeah
you know it would be a nice vehicle but
hey you know say I never saw that
happening and and unfortunately you know
there are gonna be some people that
gonna say hey how dare you I'm not
paying for anything after
you know what I got initially also may
be on a wait-and-see kind of basis so
nobuseri plays up so new weapons armor
and Van Leer awards to collect we'll see
if they matter of course random roles
and hopefully armor perks make things
different we'll see new and returning
exotics of course they're gonna keep the
returning back I do honestly hope if
they're gonna return more and more d1
back that they don't reset it again for
d3 if they do that it's like well you
can't do that for a third time a third
game yeah I agree
at this point it's like keep everything
existing and then you know move forward
at this point I don't want to hear about
the vault blew up again and you know I
know like just the one time and then I
think we're good you gonna use that
Mulligan once yeah new pinnacle
activities so it's just gonna be in em
type stuff I don't know what that
involves just more nightfall level stuff
or challenges or prestige that's my only
guests I don't know I mean this is
interesting terminology not to cut you
but like if you really look at it annual
pass right yeah annual so again does
this mean they're changing models um
they have to be a little bit like yeah I
agree shot the father to chat he said
yes since they're making money off these
trends microtransactions nation adopted
DLC yeah I mean I would love it I would
love it in a perfect world I just know
that activision got their hands on this
we're gonna pay there is no doubt about
it I don't see them getting from
underneath that but um it's curious the
terminology now so again maybe they're
going away from expansion 1 and 2
normally they would do like expansion 1
& 2 which would be like winter and
spring combo deal you get it for what 45
bucks or something like that 35 or 40
bucks yeah 35 I think for 35 or 40 for
each separate that's right
but now it looks like that throwing that
third that summer yep that pretty much
seems like to change I sounds like they
should just have a third piece in there
so spring earlier so what do you have
winters always gonna be like December
basically typically it seems to be there
always December then you'll have March
and then what like June yeah month and
then you'll do whatever d2
a forsaken 2.0 in the fall or something
like that I'm exactly however you have
your annual cycle sale mm-hmm hopefully
we'll get more details but yeah let's
get back to it
you guys look three two one go go
you
story you know all by faint going like
that but if they put some lower back in
the game in a different way
this is gonna be contentious with the
law community though yeah but if you
don't own it well they made that mistake
once they won't do that again some stuff
is still gonna be normal for seasons
yep mmm interesting signs my head oh
we're gonna go check the bungy site
after this
oh that pause just posit seven let's go
this is our point okay so one point two
point one is that one point two point
three six three six quickly 6v6 quick
play they listened they listened
permanent rumble playlist there you go
Bounty's I still want to know what
they're doing with that cuz that could
be good or could be useless I just still
don't know raid layer prestige we still
don't know much July 17th is your data
I've so didn't even look right yep ty
seventeen year one triumphs so that'll
be your destiny two year one triumphs
shirt or money Lord stuff to complete
more exotic armor sandbox changes it's
so far like I mean Luna faction boots is
breaking the game right now have you
know what they doing oh my god they cuz
it boosts the range when you go
empowering grift they gonna sell it's at
Calais and one plate him with shotguns
no yes basically almost one plate him
with shotguns it is insane
we're doing and they're using shot shot
ease on the bads to with little purple
hanging things they're literally just
melting everything we're shotgun
citizens because it's blue the damage
because I was like I don't I don't know
I mean yeah they're gonna have to build
around it or something but yeah that's
right now so I gotta see - haven't seen
it yeah I gotta go get me I got a great
some rating in because I have to say
that it'll definitely be here so so
1.2.3 I don't know where one point two
point two went because that just
apparently felt
so year two let's go down September
fourth we have a date election they're
trying to jump ahead of everything in
September because it's September but we
had official date yeah September 4th
with a first okay oh no they're barely
they're barely ahead of spider-man it's
like a few days later maybe I think I
thought it was so single digit number so
yeah was it like Friday or Thursday here
but they should listen one thing about
destiny I will say is this I they will
withstand the blunt of any single player
game in my opinion they will take a base
for a while and then you know it's gonna
play games so just at the end of the day
it's the it's the big you know the big
guys you know the arm you know right
dad's in the Call of Duty's and you know
I'm saying that kind of stuff because if
we assuming readiness gonna have some
kind of uh I'm assuming but um
yeah you know saying but I'm glad I
shout the sleet was their only chance at
bounties mmm
but um yet it did September fourth man I
like it I like the date get out as early
as possible pretty much
oh you're gonna have collared reading
battlefield both in October but still
gives you that that's five weeks I think
from both depending on the dates I
forget assault 19th and then read dad's
obviously November but I mean give you
the kind of get settled get out there
see what people are like in check I'm
sorry
know if you get enough you know people
at least enjoying it for a while even if
they step away to try other things you
know you might be able to pull them back
again with a step in the right direction
with whatever's in December so you'll
have people play for a while work on
their stuff and then maybe come back
with another shut up to zero he saying
Spider Man Tomb Raider and spiral all
around at same time and that's true
again I would but I've always felt
destiny can always withstand they did
they need to avoid people in their genre
all that the multi player only kind of
game yeah and I think that gives them a
nice little window before what is it
October
yeah October's battlefield card yeah
yeah that's when you yeah hits you know
saying in the player base yeah so we got
in game triumph store so gear
collections weapon slot change I still
want more details on that hopefully
we'll get there in a second weapon
randomization again that's just a big
thing just for the grind so if I get a
better devils I don't get my fourth one
it might have been different like that
alone gives you a reason to look
everything you pick up because most of
the time it doesn't matter anymore right
now it does not matter so I'm curious if
they're gonna do randoms for all the
weapons that are out there
that's a good question if they go and go
all you know what if you can now get
randoms on better devil suit me better
Devils as about as good as it's probably
gonna get right I mean what about some
of the other ones in there like a crappy
pulse rifle and you can react they hope
this applies to existing weapons not
just anything from forsaken moving
forward you don't mean yeah I know
yeah don't don't make all those good
weapons that you had absolutely give
those weapons a chance to have random
roles so now people can find some hidden
gems right with weapons that we thought
were crappy and now they've got you know
proper perk slots with some changes now
you talk them about that grind that
investment for the perfect weapon again
like that's what we want you know I mean
mmm
absolutely so some of these builds are
probably gonna be bananas what if you're
like you're just the one run around in
it see I actually kind of like before we
even go any farther I usually like the
idea of that for a raid what if your job
is literally like you stay on the
farthest back plate and just pick stuff
off if that's just ya crowd control just
pick stuff on headshots here and there
pick stuff up tell people if somebody
else is running them you keep the focus
you're like a DPS I wish they would
still go a little bit harder with stuff
like that like hey if I start sniping
somebody and somebody's running up to
you to do some no mechanic or use a
relic or something you're still on me
cuz I have the aggro by damage like if
you could do something like that with a
Titan wall and peek out and hit the
damage you're using oh and they're doing
stuff that'd be cool like that'd be cool
I wish they would go just a little more
listen do you know yeah the end of day
gives it gives customization gives that
freedom you know yeah would you I play
how you want to play so that's good mod
system update this has got to be about
the armor now this is the one that has
me question like mods right now weapons
are like you have a damage that you've
kinetic it just gives you a point bonus
that's it which is they still need more
mods for guns to like let me have the
range finder mod let me have a you know
anything just let me get a better scope
that I could just
a little harder into that I want to see
links so I mean I got to get some weapon
mods that actually met or armor mods
that matter so different roles to mod
slots let me go like extra here extra
here all that stuff so mods is one that
I definitely want to see I love how bulk
shader deletion yes it's a big boy we
figured that delete a hundred shaders
and we will break your game it's like
that should not be on this list that
should be I should surely be ineffective
dear brag it is so funny yeah don't
don't brag on oh please yeah honestly
like I mean some people would want to
know you might be like hey and you'll be
able to delete other shaders just say it
once in chat or tweet it out but not on
your roadmap new crucible mode there's a
new mode no that's the new game mode
period like new usable because that's
not just PvP new crucible mode what like
rift but it says new well you never know
it could be a new 4d new identity - yeah
so 200 edition of all slots
Oh holla that's a ok give me a thousand
or pages or you stop it cuz you're gonna
give us like 30 more shaders I already
don't have enough space for the ones I
have and unless you figure out gifts at
if they get rid of the shader situation
I don't think they're going to because
they have a bulk shader deletion so
they're not gonna let you get rid of
them or have a collection because you're
gonna be able to delete them which still
sucks Oh
anyway 200 some but never enough Lord
now that's one whereby Fizz like pale
yeah that's big and I actually like that
they put that as a tab yeah tries to
reassure the law community that they're
going to take it serious but then they
say things like yeah it's about the
actions you do with this season past
thing so I'm a little conflicted if how
dedicated they are to it we'll see we'll
see what are you thinking I mean just
the fact that the lore is in there if
you can go in check on a tab you're like
hey what's this and it's got something
in game like the grimoire cards before
should have been in there before like
you that's your that's how you evolved
do you wanted you to like grimoire cards
on bungie.net to grimoire cards in game
if you're gonna do something like that
for
your grimoire cards and things to look
at and more stuff that's a little more
accessible yes so I'm okay with it I
just kind of want to know and I'm sure
by fonts all the details he's like give
me give me give me give me give me
course yeah of course his job is like
well crap now it's all in the game I
guess I have to interpret and
extrapolate the theories so listen
zeroed I'm not screaming victory for law
yet I'm happy there's a tab that says in
game Lord yes
but remember when they were talking and
you'll pass and they were like yeah it's
gonna be less cinematic and then another
that's what I'm like let's pump the
brakes question so for the cinematic
when it's like so what if they take out
the cinematic of you flying into the
raid or you know they take about the
traffic of the cinematic cinematics as
it is when it comes to certain stuff
things they don't like that's why take
it out was it about blank that's but if
you have a cohesive voice chat as you go
on or what if it's like so
I mean God of War say it's you and your
son what if it's more of a discussion
about things as you walk around as
you're walking around you have like you
know K Brera
that was so that kind if it goes that
direction with more voiceover in-game
action as you go be like hey okay this
guy's crazy I remember locking him up in
prison because they talk about a prison
break for the story
like I remember locking this guy up he's
crazy watch him he's it's not the fact
that they have a one of those Baron
fights and it's a sniper battle I like
that
like so those are action set-pieces but
if you have discussion in between
throughout and say you can reference it
later say here's a voice things activate
it's like story mission number one go
back here listen to what Kade says you
could play it back listen that would at
least help so hey just I hate to do it
is to your cuz you are real positive
right now no I'm just saying it's if
those are steps in a direction where
there's more of it even even if it's in
game it's still better than some of the
stuff we have now so I'm saying it's
like better than not I hear you this is
Bungie and they're their track record
has shown that they have not committed
to Lauria and up until to this point
like we still we've had two DLCs to
prove it again I want to give them the
benefit of the doubt
please trust me I don't want to be
negative Nancy but this is the like the
sword thing like that
right now that it's like refusing to be
the story game right it's it's the
action to go get it the loot the chase
all that's fun that's what keeps us
going but I again I like that they did
this you know saying I just wanted to
temper expectations with it because
we've seen you know we we have a lot of
roadmap to provoke the show of what
they've done in terms of respecting law
and respecting that's all I'm saying
mmm but I'm happy it's there in the tag
you did I'm here so of the three parts
of the annual release by the way I
looked up penumbra yes number is the
part of eye shadow where the light
source is only partially blocked mm-hmm
Oh PO number son the ring shaped semi
bright region of the Sun spot that
surrounds the darker Umbra so somewhere
between light and dark is basically what
that sounds like what sounds like yeah
wait a minute I'm sorry
I skips and that's something I got
excited about I am so sorry that last
sentence just meant it's hit my heart
I'm sorry you didn't we weren't there
yet I glanced and saw something I should
have sorted well get to it get to go go
we have new bounties so they're bounties
and the new bounties and then power
matters and iron manner and trials DLC
of the year you're good I'm good now now
I'm good I'm talking about now this
gives me I'm gonna bring it back now
oh no I'm pooping all over Bungie okay
throw them in there because in the more
I am banner power matters
yeah that's respecting the law that's
what I'm talking about let's go we were
saying anyways continue once you've lost
all composure yeah I'll take that out
but I'm telling you right now man that's
a huge deal partner and trials and iron
banner huge deal man that's what it's
about
that grind to get that level you should
have somewhat an advantage in little
difficult activities especially if you
crying
you know I mean and respects the law
continue alright so and more mm-hmm
so I mean we already play destiny enough
as it is
I play it more than I should but I mean
for a year - is this a taken king level
movement it seems like it has a chance
to be so far it feels there's only one
thing I feel this thing feels great
there's only one thing I feel taken King
had over it though which may taken King
like the ultimate because they're
mimicking the bad bosses with the raids
I like that they do one's a lot of new
mode they're doing a lot of cool stuff
to bring all our destiny one
customization all that remember though
taking King debuted new subclasses now
we're not getting them we're getting
these variations which is cool supers
basically right exactly
now the thing is as far as the armed
enemy types - Connor on it I didn't see
did you see anything falling but they're
like fallen different for someone
different it definitely they're fun but
I mean as it's still besties - I'm not
sure this is the time where they go and
develop just the same with taken King
there's a reskin of guys different
animations things like that but using a
similar models I can only imagine like
the time it takes to build some of that
stuff and they still build the
animations on top of those so I'm sure
it's still falling with like
skins and armor and things like that but
I mean honestly space Doritos being the
darkness I think that is gonna be
probably a d3 type thing I don't think
that is gonna be this so I mean that's
that's the time that's the scale of
thing I think you do because in the
scale of when you do the original story
for do - it goes you release the light
of the traveler it hit mer three right
it is the order in Mars in the reef the
darkness whatever those black ships are
they turned on yeah they wouldn't do
that if there wasn't a plan well
hopefully so they finally a full circle
and gave us some idea who the stranger
is so mmm-hmm you know hats off to a
little bit of that but yeah so I think
we've rambled on about speculation they
could answer half
our questions here right oh right here
we just stopped it cuz we go yeah I was
like we just had to it's a road map this
is our thing I drove that flash point
Ashley mode is this last point long
point exam all right let's get it back
going 28 27 3 2 1 kill Oh
you
any fun if they gonna break it down just
like we did
what is the solstice of heroes still
don't know what that's gonna be
it is this is very fun Scott's just like
uh-huh can't say anything
they're hyped for that and it's like a
summer thing I still want to know mmm
let's go yeah we find bana everyone mmm
yeah you're bringing it but they
listened I mean they try it and yeah mmm
TAS gonna be happy about that rumble in
Emporia he's a beast
nice so thick 4v4 quick plays going away
it would be nice there we go yeah all
right let's hear it let's hear it
yo DZ The Fool he said shaders are
evolving crossing fingers mm-hmm thank
God
yeah mm-hmm
Destin Lee Geary smiles yeah
has to go up yeah yeah in which capacity
I just want to make sure the old oh all
the woman's room
thank you
Tsang armor mm-hmm yeah depth is
important so it makes people come back
mhm
Thanks oh here we go here we go here we
go
here we go
hmm yeah they still got some lot
explaining
hmm sounds like you just get an option
to pick whatever there's more things
they're gonna be in those two slots
basically
oh you see what caused that real quick
pause it
334 730 407 what yeah did you hear
because I was like trying to replace say
he hinted that he said the new stuff you
get to see in different slots the new
stuff yeah again I don't want to catch
them out of context maybe you just
making the blanket state like if it just
has the warmind icon is not the only
thing that has it there that's the
question yeah after the worship if
there's there's only so many archetypes
though depending on roles and things
like that
usually they have a few extra but I mean
how many kinetic sniper rifles do you
really need no I not get that I
understand that I'm not I'm not like but
you're just saying they're probably not
gonna go back and redo everything that's
a lot of work I'll be there think about
like in their defense right if you if
we're gonna make everything see my only
concern now again is the role see the
roles I need that to be what's the word
retro rock
yeah retro yeah first-rate so I need
that to be retroactive but you know the
slats I'm okay if they like hey forsaken
weapons can move around as long as they
give you a decent variety I'm okay with
that - yeah they need to go into detail
I notice is the first reveal stream I'm
not gonna get I'm not gonna beat them
over there this is them just telling us
all this new stuff plethora of
information that's cool you know I did
one where as we move further along as we
get closer we'll see how that breakdown
works as far as the slots I'm just
curious
you know can I put play of the game in
the Fuhrer in the committee yeah
like if you could move some of that
stuff around that'd be really nice just
to have what you haven't be like all
right fusion fusion rocket like just
somebody else how do you think that's
gonna work in PvP though that's why I'm
surprised cause the vibe I'm not getting
which is which is really was like
interesting is I thought they would take
like a Call of Duty
point number point like yeah right so
like when you put something in a certain
slot that's gonna take a listen you got
a 10-point system right and that's gonna
take up a six you know because moved you
know whatever whatever into head you
know that
you move sins of the past into the
primary yeah some ridiculous reason but
yes exactly so now okay you only got a
couple of points to play with with your
other two and that way limits you to
specific weapon types like a sidearm or
whatever right and being that everything
would have sort of quote unquote like a
value right so I'm not getting that you
and I said it doesn't exist but the
bottom they looking like they sounding
like you could just move around what
they say in three shotguns right yeah I
mean I think the way cuz like if I think
about the graphic it shows the white one
for your kinetics shows the green two
for your energy and the purple like free
free so maybe it's just whatever icon of
that type is on that weapon that's the
slot it can fill maybe there are kinetic
snipers but maybe you can also have
another sniper but basically whatever
slot that thing can fill that's what it
is maybe it's I don't know that's my
guess but it's gonna be interesting it's
very interesting back to ya three two
one
sorry for all the kind of guys sorry yep
they're not done all right so there's a
one one oh no hold on boss yeah puss
okay I'm at 35 23 so now you got a 1 and
a 1 you think that racking up there in
one that's still kinetic but also looks
to be like a kinetic I swear I have that
sitting on a character holding let me
look at it
it looks like that crappy scout rifle
and I swear it's normally is that energy
normally but it's still a 1:1 but it
says 1 because that looks like either
like that's a pulse or a scout it's the
metronome 52 I think ok no patrol
Houyhnhnm James yeah
oh wait no that's not right yeah kind of
like a little stripe on the begun swift
ride is what it looks like ok so this
isn't at the pulse
uh yeah ok yeah but that always was
there yeah that's there but it's still
counting as that once one anyway alright
so I'm at 35 23 where you want it the
same thing again alright 3 2 1 go yeah I
love how the light level isn't too high
right now mm-hmm
of oh yeah I had no idea yeah I want
this Oh
mobility resilience and recovery just to
be different no way there you go 575
works-in-progress holy crap mm-hmm yeah
the placeholder metal is epic yeah
placeholder beast mm-hmm this is like
year of triumph type stuff mm-hmm
yeah hey at least they're showing it to
us small-block a large block remotes MVP
lockers invading yeah this is it's like
basically your years of trying book this
is age of triumph tech stuff it's
definitely on PC by the refresh rate yes
you can tell that one just because it's
butters move peepee thank God for
Lourdes that's all buttload of lawyer
so there will be cutscenes but other
stuff too other stuff see that's
actually a good thing
there's quoting a way that like if you
see it go look at it later yes
see that's the type of stuff
mm-hm I feel like like my story build a
whole life for a minute I had this I
want to see 349 weapons
do exotics cuz I had duck rolls they're
not gonna show me the other one go over
one I want to see can you just pick it
up no come on go over go over go over
Gophers
Wow he's going new monarchy huh please
business in your heavy slot that's
interesting
mm-hmm
Oh for the men on scout rifle go get
gunsmith packages like yeah and that's
pretty much the only way to get that gun
hmm I want to see armor I want to see
armor
the t's 948 I know the numbers don't
matter so I'm flare
what the hell's flare yeah motes flare
EEMA there's not - I'm emotes i guess
would that be gotta be mo Ohno
everything emotes of endless shaders
shaders okay so shaders are in there why
do I need to get rid of a stack that I
want to know hopefully that involves
mm-hmm 15 pieces of thank you for the
movie yes waiting I love this right now
sorry appreciate - no they they're out
there oh of course they're just there
yes
I want to see how the damn weapons work
you know you don't get that right I know
- leaking shaders that ilayk crazy yeah
I know I will be there yeah you'll be
there
that's a we clear
actually it is pretty cool kind of
digging that yeah yeah
mium all with lucky man
- purse your hymen out
put it in 160 seconds yep I call there's
a 60-second ride out
and let's see in Ted time to freak out
again yes sir
I'm gonna is it going yeah I'm still
counting here miles counter just stuck
on the tini
yes RB there we go there we go I like
that logo - mmm what brought what gun
was that that's insane
those barons look sick that sword looks
ornate yeah
what that is yeah look how a ship
actually just bombed stuff for a fire
tornado tell you what the tides got it
this year just pause it there leave it
on the logo 46 47 46 48 for me mm-hmm
yeah I mean this is this is impressive
this is impressive um I'm just like I'm
like okay okay like you can kind of set
it the same way it's like so we have
more info than we use soon we also have
more questions than we used to
absolutely we still got a deep dive you
know get more information on this but um
fantastic start I think that the main
beefs of the community from the you know
the web we've always said this from that
you know the original flash point said
you know yeah randomization weapon rolls
you know does a huge you know got guys
like you know doc and needs your stuff
like that like these these are the
things that were keeping them from
coming back you know and to see that
stuff implemented new mode you know new
abilities it just it looks cool I have
some reservations with certain things
but you know I'm excited this is this is
nice direction
you don't say what's your uh what's your
mindset well you know I mean I'm
definitely digging it right now I'm
trying to open a couple things I might
actually switch over on stream here so I
mean I'm looking a lot of this so far
like I'm digging just about everything
we got here to kind of an amazing level
of like I'm quite late yeah absolutely I
mean it's definitely one that there are
still more questions I have and there's
no question I think all of us have those
questions but that being said I do think
they are taking lots of steps in the
right direction a PvE and PvP combined
thing that's that's the one that people
couldn't put down like I remember
Guardian radio talking about it being
like dude I didn't want to stop playing
like
I mean just a different piece just a
little bit you said the community people
who got to go and play the thing or like
I did don't want to stop and I'm like
that out of people who are like either
down on destiny or didn't want to and
they didn't want to put the controller
down that's a good sign in itself so
yeah there's like so many super
questions there's a bow and arrow now
which sounds so weird in this game
that's good so cool like I mean it could
be awesome so you've got the crazy
pirate you've got the ninja of Deadpool
hunter you've got a fire I mean I don't
know how many things I can say from like
a 1 minute little blip to go holy crap
yeah it's a lot going on there's
definitely a lot going on um I I just
want a deep dive you guys I just want to
get more information
yeah break it down even further but
definitely definitely hi definitely you
know a lot of positive stuff I just want
to keep things I'm trying to keep even
keel I guess I'm only from the
standpoint you know we we've been hurt
before you know say and this looks
fantastic like even the whole ring stuff
like I'm liking what I'm hearing I just
you've got the Dreaming city or
something like yeah I heard somebody so
tweets and stuff I saw like dreaming
city seems like the home of the awoken
yes which is my favorite it's my
favorite race that's like you've got
that you've got more raid bosses than
ever but you've got an endgame area that
connects to the raid that that alone is
a good start if you have like an area
you explore and be like hey you have a
different zone you have to the launched
the raid or something but if you're
connecting you're in the area and you
get something about it before you go in
just the fact that there's a chance to
have some lore some connection to a
story to go into the raid that's a start
yeah absolutely yeah absolutely we see
the Forsaken has a raft a second appears
and stuff people who you know I respect
and you know people who are very down on
destiny to you know to see the positive
reaction from a lot of people and I'm
just like okay alright they didn't
Christie I'm
like I mean I'm in our bubble right I'm
like so us I'm like yeah I'm excited you
know but I'm always concerned like how
does this affect the person that hasn't
played does this entice them you know
yeah and I'm seeing again it's my little
small echo chamber but I'm seeing people
actually getting excited and I'm like
whoa when I got my boy Fonzarelli
hitting me up like did you see it and
this was like a guy that bashed it d2
from launch you know you know and I got
other people you know that that put
destiny to down there telling me yo did
you see it I'm like no cuz me box is
gonna do a live blind reaction Street I
know like no I didn't look leave me
alone shut up you know that's where I
bet but yeah man I can't wait
cannot wait so a couple of those things
that took me a little bit to get there
if you go to destiny the game.com you'll
come to the four second page if you want
to do that on yours because that's what
I'm looking at right now you got like
the reveal the pre-order for second I
left and but on the right and you'll
pass and then you can pre-order your
editions and look at a little bit more
detail to see kind of what's in there so
you get the game digital deluxe are you
did you make it over to look at that no
I did not I did not you have it on your
screen yeah I do know I'll give you less
and Sharon rice right now bro oh here we
go so you is it working yeah are you
seeing what I'm seeing
okay cool so so for page one mmm oh this
is what it looks like first up top so
just a fly and just a little teaser you
know forsaken on the left you can learn
more about that Jace kind of nut short
happens if I click on that but will stay
on the pages for now damn but as well
PVE pvp combined annual pass so black
armory Joker's wild now one two three
four five six seven eight nine hmm oh no
wait three 3 that's 8 I can't take yeah
what do one in the middle is 9 oh hey no
no maybe that could be the night and pin
number that way yeah what is it
okay what'd you go save up a number oh
that's the light versus the dark let's
like tour the shadow of the light
changes so you got like kind of almost
look like a spiraling Eclipse no because
while does an interesting name for a DLC
destiny like yeah like it's like a
barracks like he's in there like just
crafted a casino wiki what's going on we
gotta go get a drink you know stuff
things and stuff so I don't know black
armory I mean I can see that making
sense you have these don't want I mean
yeah it's obscure enough they can do
whatever but yet that one's weird I
don't know but you got your additions
standard forsaken plus a no pass digital
deluxe edition so let me go over to page
2 so for a second digital deluxe
following years of following years of
strife what remains of the reef has
fallen to lawlessness you and Kate are
sent to personally investigate the
recent unrest upon arrival you soon
discover the most wanted criminals and
prison of elders have organized an
escape beyond the Vanguard's Authority
you'll you'll pursue these features of
deep in the reef explore new regions
awaken new powers and powerful weapons
in uncovered long-lost awoken secrets
hunt is on so hunt down the eight barons
and their crew now just the fact that
there's eight barons I don't know how
many stories they're gonna be if their
strikes involved like how those are
gonna get broken up again lower
questions to new destinations tangled
Shore which looks like the Old West of
the reef and then The Dreaming City
which looks really cool brand new raid
of course gambits a 44 4v4 competitive
PvE with a twist mode that one alone I
mean now here's the thing if you do
gambit and all you get is like a blue
and you finish that's you know you've
got to have like some gambit exclusive
stuff you got to have some gambit perks
you've got to have those type of things
need to be in there too it can't just be
like hey here's a random role piece of
armor give me like those if that's
another pillar of the game it needs to
have its own pieces to it so hopefully
wield new powers with nine additional
Super's 909 edition that's crazy
so three classes right now only one ok
I'm relieved now 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
so each subclass gets a completely
different super I wonder okay think
about if they have the super on the left
right now splits to the two trees right
do you think if they would put the other
super on the other side and still go to
the same trees or different trees of
perks like what do you think because I
mean it has new supers
most of the perks go to in some way to
the supers like either it's a ward of
dawn you get that or it's the shield you
get another throw like those perk trees
are very specific so it's gonna have to
be another super and other per trees
yeah it's gonna be a must I think it has
to be a must
9 Wow that dad I'm glad we went to this
page this this answers a lot wow I mean
that's an accent every single subclass
that's impressive that's what I mean we
got a new subclass and taking king with
its own super we get a new super 4
exactly yeah actually take it back I
take about that substantial that is
substantial so that's probably one of
the biggest things I've seen even yet um
collect new exotic weapons armor gear
yeah all new weapon archetype legendary
bow I'm kind of curious now so a bow
travel time like a fusion rifle shot
interested to see yeah it's not gonna be
like a hitscan weapon it can't be can't
be it can't be hits game well if you
think it's like a sniper rifle you hit
him in the head on the move done like
one shot in PvP this is like this is
some next-level like new swords before
how'd that go right did but this is like
a projectile weapon with you know of
assuming some type of travel time so yes
someone can keep up with any a sniper
anyone it may be more ammo cuz you're
gonna miss maybe quicker hiring times
this is gonna be light medium and
heavier different levels of bows too so
I don't even know how that
maybe like I said you know yeah that's a
good point let's compile I think it
could be like one of those things where
it's a skill weapon and um you know kind
of like a sniper you know like um you
know in the sense that you know that
like damaging ones you know may have the
faster rate of fire that kind of deal
they may go that route you know I'm
saying everyone's obviously the one oh
okay now picture a Boeing PvE
that's the one I can't picture like it
compares ago but I've got an auto rifle
like aerials gift with range consistency
I've got vigils I've got so many other
things how is that gonna compare because
to be practical
you should technically probably only
have so many arrows unless they're just
energy based which they probably are too
instead well I mean are they gonna
pierce are they gonna go through things
are oh so many questions
hello is gödel but this is the same
thing we said when uh when when swords
got announced like how are they gonna do
swords in a game with then event and we
like oh yeah so I got we got confidence
and it's just gonna be implementation
how they gonna you know do that giant
but I'm still can't get over the super
strike that you I'm glad yeah 9 1 for
every sub that's gotta be another set of
perjuries because those yeah they
connect too well to their current like
void titan they're related to either you
know shield throwing or lord have done
like those are not gonna be related to
whatever the void one is like there's
and and it's nice the fact that we get
late we get them all we don't get like
some now some with summer right this
year the more second this is all of them
right now and what I like is again it
goes back to that d1 thing we've always
wanted that level of customization that
deep dive remember staying in your
subclass tree and having those choices
for every situation what should I use
what's most effective you throw that now
with the weapon roles you know I'm
saying weapon slot changes you know it
now becomes this this almost domino
effect of being a deep game again you
know they like it means that so
no III go for a car I'm feeling jelly
Mary I'm feeling jelly like I just
listen it's the hunters time right cuz
I'll see your Saturdays whatever but
it's like bro y'all got it right now a
bullet barrier reflecting say the
Deadpool did you got the golden ninja
stars and like yo let's think through
the classes so you had so hunter you had
Golden Gun which had golden throwing
names yes hunter arc Steph arc Strider
had arcs pity shield Corliss channel 5
baby just getting it getting a channel
for their yeah but you gotta be old
enough to understand the reference
well it's basically a kung fu reference
wheeze like oh you know you didn't you
still I think Killick from Soul Calibur
yeah it's nothing can touch me but he's
mastered art that's okay so then void
hunter mm-hmm no think is that the sword
do we think we saw that one swipe oh do
you think yeah yeah I don't know though
Titan we have Superman that's all
arc Superman and then void fire torn can
you kill are you kidding me like I'm
sorry but like a giant hammer shoots the
wave of fire into a fire tornado I mean
if you want to melt a group of enemies
or a boss everything in front of you and
then the end game of that run dice like
insane that's insane
and then the blue this is better than
having a new so you didn't variations on
everything you know as an extra option
cuz I mean we just got one more
something that's one yep with like two
per trees it's got nine perk trees
doubled by us and this is a reason this
is why they can't go here three you
start it all over you can't pull this
work here and go like no all right you
forgot everything lost on this was
actually Total Recall
you're actually on Mars and you're out
the Sims go exactly uh yeah and then
warlock had the war pee little war poor
poor boy ding
no look like when Wonder Woman warping
her and then the kamehameha my motto for
the Dodgers gotta see how its
implemented you know say cuz again yeah
everything else from all the other
critics is so much flashy so again it
could be very effective it could be you
know how it is power
well think about like take storm collars
very close what do I get in the back and
I just super from whatever range and G's
a long distance long distance major
military legs right and which which for
the teleporting warlock trying to think
what class that was what was void yeah
cuz arc is the like beam and I saw the
only thing we haven't seen is there
don't lead the solar warlock the solar
warlock we haven't seen the void Titan
and the void so there was a sword look I
couldn't tell if that was the exotic
sword though like that sword swipe so I
think there's three we haven't seen
probably since Justin man I'm hive that
see that got behind what is going so for
you the big high points I have gathered
nine supers and power matters and trials
and those are your two selling points
throw your money up the screen you're
done yeah mom damn I forgetting
something else too um power level medals
at Rose yeah I mean come on we can't the
weapons you know I'm saying the weapon
we've known for a while though true but
to be on I think even though the weapon
slot stuff is cool for me weapon random
roles that's my thing that's my minutiae
so those are my three right there off
the off the rip and yet I mean just like
the locales of everything looks cool it
looks like there's multiple aspects of
this going into the prison of elders who
knows what they had
you know how cake aid was doing it man
yours and put monsters in there now we
got to find these barons or whatever the
hell's going on you know that sounds
cool I'm
oh the awoke in that what does it call
the dream city dreaming city yeah the
dreaming so you know that I'm gonna
walking at that when I remember first
turning on destiny and I was looking at
that character miles like I'm very
intrigued with that so just to see this
you know go into that you know the law
regarding that is very interesting to me
so yeah those are my what about you
what's your top highlights of this thing
man of the four sake I mean I freaked
out the most over the Super's just
because variety in gameplay is fun armor
perks I still need more there that's
what they said it I just need to know
what those armor perks and mods actually
are gonna do mm-hmm yes well I mean
weapons lot random or weapons slot
changes seemed honestly more than I
expected because we figured it was gonna
be like hey specials are an option or
there's gonna be a for special slot now
it's like kind of run whatever your
options that drop are like that is
actually almost that's something we
didn't expect and that's why I think
people are saying it's like whether you
whatever you wanted you were gonna be
happy and I think whoever said that from
I heard it from somebody talking about
the summit they're like whichever
version of this thing you want you're
probably gonna be fine and I think most
people are going to be able to get what
they want out of it if you want to be a
sniper in PvP and you got a kinetic and
then you got an energy hand cannon BAM
so you're running a kinetic sniper you
got Sun shot you got a rocket launcher
that's back to be one you want to run
two different Scouts do you want to one
vigilance wing and graviton Lance you
got your options if you're medium or far
right and then you can throw a shoddy
down on the bike I mean I think it'd
give us a lot of variety and you know
again we didn't guess that one yeah and
I'm not getting the vibe that exotics
are moving slats don't we keeping
exotics not run exotics are gonna stay
in slide I would assume it it seems like
there's gonna be I mean it seems but
that one thing they had that looked like
an energy weapon still had a number one
like it was kinetic in the middle that's
what threw me off from like like what
King is kinetic it was the pulse right
yes yes yes Swift right or whatever
there was like wait yeah that's why does
that have a normal thing on it like huh
so no I mean somebody somebody in your
chat saying like hey somebody's back
they literally like they're running them
through the story they bought the DLC to
catch up just because the reveal
I mean it's surprising to me because
again we you know we've seen how much
damage destiny 2 is done at the launch
and I've got I'm getting my people like
fawns you got my boy Reaper you know
saying I got this I got people who look
just like eff destiny I'm not going back
and them seeing this it's just
surprising to me like cuz I'm keeping my
expectations in check and everybody's I
know this is it probably concern on
watch cactus video to be like destiny
saved I'm like alright I know everything
you probably know I'm like wow this
thing really had a positive effect and I
think it just comes down to just giving
the people exactly what they wanted and
and and and you know what they did well
to e they made us feel powerful again in
these this vid Ock right now they made
us feel like yo about exactly so I think
that I think whatever that team they've
really conveyed that well because people
people are so far I don't you know
people seem in people seem to be
invigorated hi
finally annual pass they talked about
long signed seasonal updates live events
every for every player for this new to
forsaken annual pass provides bonus
rewards introduces three premium content
releases winter spring and summer we
know about that wrath
so the awoken Legend set which I guess
comes with a digital deluxe wrath [ __ ]
wrath majestic legendary bow ornament
okay I don't know how many boaters
they're gonna have the dirge paladin
emblem don't know random emblem Michelle
and fireteam medallions whoo that's here
mm-hm
and then so destiny too so we've got the
only story innovative game modes
powerful weapons gear all of them annual
pass has all that and in the digital
deluxe which is just a little bit of
cosmetic stuff so it's like just your
basics for buying the cosmetics so final
pages here definitely forsaken we got a
couple pictures so we got okay
I need a need to make that picture
bigger hold on let me see if I can zoom
hey there we go we got bigger okay he's
saying that grimoires back yeah
basically it looks like in that lower
section somewhere there's a way to go
back and look at almost everything
you've done you know that's a that's a
good that's a good do and consolidate
and so what more you missing and that's
pretty cool so for Digital Deluxe that's
full annual pass everything altogether
seventy-nine okay I mean so the so it's
the game and then your expansion pass
price basically and then the five bucks
probably different for this one no guess
the other ones probably a smidgen smidge
less like I think I saw it was sixty
nine ninety nine for the combo yeah and
then ten bucks more for the digital
deluxe which if you want to get
cosmetics it's fine but seventy dollars
for I mean how many hours are you gonna
play this game come on there's gonna be
they're gonna get some pushback though
from Petersburg going to but I was like
so games have gotten cheaper and cheaper
and cheaper and there's a point where
people have to understand in everything
else in the world has cost more houses
the Cotters everything else in life and
everybody's like oh no a game should
only be 60 or 40 or I want to wait for a
humble bundle deal I was like you have
any idea how much goes into making a
game anymore
and it's like they won't trade a/c
montes you're falling for the trap
because you I'm telling you I'm not
giving plenty another cent and dad's
choice and that's fine that is your
choice but also think about how many
people complain about a game they're
still playing true but you you guys are
suckers because they do this to you
every year I'm not giving them a cent
man they burnt me and that's it that's
no here's the thing like how does
fortnight survive it is one game mode on
basically one map and they have some
seasonal changes but they have cosmetics
and that's it now here you have a story
with cinematics and a campaign you have
a new game mode you have six supers you
can say how long they said like one
weapon they said like a passive exotics
takes like months to make so I
this stuff like if you don't want to
support bungees that's fine but in the
grand scheme of things for me the amount
of hours I put in I put two thousand
hours into destiny one and as caveats
you said it's like mmo's used to have a
subscription i paid fourteen bucks a
month for that thing for years they got
a buttload more than whatever i don't
you ever paid Bungie for this so to me
80 bucks for a year of like it if this
is your game and this is like hey I want
to play this for a year I want to enjoy
all the content apparents like hey I buy
this 180 bucks you know this is your
destiny for a year you might get a few
others but you can get a year out of
this that's a good value I hey I listen
know nothing I don't know I just tell
you I'm just what you're gonna have the
whiny babies and crap like that that's
why yeah so but I was like look at this
picture right here you have this dude
looking like he's kneeling down he's all
the take him ish I don't even know
what's going on in the background here I
don't know what's going on in the back
that looks cool that looks like what is
the night before Nightmare Before
Christmas or something yeah that looks
like The Nightmare Before Christmas helm
and then he's got a comment down below
and like tubes come out of the chest and
a knapsack and and then the warlock in
the background has got all that dreaming
hmm
so here's like so this is kind of giving
it gonna give you an idea of like your
roaming around in this area's all these
little connected plop you're gonna fall
a lot yeah this is definitely jumping
it's definitely not gonna pass OSHA
requirements I'm gonna fall all the time
this is cool got your bank you've got
these okay dad let goes look like just
fire around them if they swing that
thing it's like a burning ballet like
there's they may be fallen enemies but I
think this is probably the biggest
departure from that that it looks like
I've seen like for sure that almost
looks like a new enemy type like that
that's how I treated yeah we got
dreaming stuff as you say as you said
you took Syfy and crossed with Lord of
the Rings and bam you've got the like
elf city shout out start to unique
always kill it now okay here we go
oh we got void katanas on your hunter
we just got an answer mmm okay
so void you can go Bo or you can go o
but I mean I guess it was they got all
the flats of oh look at the art on that
enemy dude art man I would just I want
it like this is another reason the art
team at Bungie alone deserves my money
yes and this is why I don't mind paying
like literally the guys over there that
may like Activision decisions or ever
verse or whatever else like there people
there who bust their ass Q's my language
they work their absolute tails off in
the and the stuff they put out is is
phenomenal it is absolutely phenomenal
the way this thing looks on PC like I
don't know of games that play this way
like you if if I had the money to get
the crazy monitor that I told you about
the 144 g-sync
HDR thousand NIT brightness crazy like
and I had another graphics card in my
computer this game would look better
than just about anything and I'm like
and I always come back for that classic
1g gameplay that gun played it we can't
get anywhere else now you can want a sub
power fantasy on top of it with
tremendous animatics that this is for
the people who don't understand that's
why we come back it's just nothing that
replicates this and from a cooperative
standpoint there's nothing that compares
to this it's it's no and I think touches
the raid nothing like nothing fine it's
it's not forty or ten or fifteen it's
six people willing yes we got down here
pre-ordering get Cades exotics - Ace of
Spades last Ace of Spades coming back
this is phase come back Queen of Hearts
exotic ship standoff exotic emote shades
of cayde-6 armor shaders premium digital
all that stuff alongside the annual
following years of strife 68 gig getting
beggar 68 what was the base price joint
what was the joint leave you if you
ain't doing a collector's edition with
the extra Chi here right here so
overtaking 40 okay and then for second
plus annual pass 70 bucks and I think if
you get the season pass I saw somewhere
by itself annual past 35 so it'd be 40
plus that soon be 74 or you buy them
together without the digital 70 but it's
buddy they're requiring the required
expansions wedded to Dave in Iraq you
know that now
mm-hmm Anton in the forsaken you know
pace maybe so destiny to game destiny
two expansions one and two and forsaken
required yeah so I wonder there so this
is if you have it already you're gonna
pre-order this one somewhere towards the
release they're gonna do here's destiny
- here's destiny - year one and a bundle
plus Forsaken you know what's coming
mm-hmm I'm sorry 104 gig of storage
space required as of 918 good Lord Jesus
I mean I was I was listening to it's
actually policy the Forbes podcast they
were talking about destiny to he was
like yeah it's gonna be like a hundred
and fifty gig on my hard drive by the
time we're done with like your three I'm
like well we're you up there so yeah we
had that book shout out the kind of
chaser did you guys talk about the new
exclusivity agreement that cuz I did not
see anything I was waiting for that like
exclusive strike or whatever but I
figured we'd get more that as we get
close to launch but I didn't see
anything no see if that's not is there
any exclusive crap on and you'll pass
annual pass you not see in place oh no I
mean I'm just seeing someone said
Activision also that forsaken launches
guy says one exclusive strike vehicle
and exotic all previous stuff Xbox gets
at launch okay so the Xbox guys are
gonna get all the borealis and all that
stuff yeah borealis and oh okay yeah I
mean listen one exclusive strike I mean
that's that's typical you know vehicle
and exotic that's typical of that damn
deal you know I'm yeah I'm used to it at
this point you know so I'm not I don't
just gotta say holders you say more no
yeah I mean listen these are as an Xbox
guy I'll get my my borealis to see what
that feels like
yeah I mean but it's like so Activision
also said were forsaken launches in
September the company will release all
of destiny choose existing for that
pay as long as it's released across all
platforms BCE mmm good yeah and like I
said at least that beast I shall Takei's
right at least that beats what happened
in taking King when we add years at
throwing Jade rabbit and all this other
foolishness so at least that has calmed
down because remember they always to
change that the verbage you know and
that that pissed a lot of people off so
you can't do that now to to communities
you know in the Xbox and know your other
PC people off they're done oh yeah I
mean it's already small out there but
this might be something that'll at least
get people excited again to come back I
mean PC gamers I think in general or
fickle with steam and like steam wire is
to play and stuff it's harder but you
give people more stuff to grind for you
go 600 power level you give a PVE pvp
you slow down the ground like you did
this time mm-hmm I was like if they can
just like implement some more story
stuff this has been a long stream though
by the way guys do yep there's a long
point love point one hour and 48 minutes
here kind of kind of had to you though
we kind of had to you know this is the
moment this is a moment these are just
some we had to do yep
so I I think that's all I can think of
now for now feel like I'm gonna go
browse YouTube and Twitter and see and
get more information and check it out
all our favorite streamers as well and
and just getting as much as possible but
man super positive step in the right
direction I'm just happy to see I'm even
killed I'll be honest I'm even killed
I'm not too too high I'm excited not too
too high I'm just glad that the effect
that I was hoping for is that it seems
to be happening on the community and not
to me is the most important to see the
community galvanized again to see the
community excited to see people who said
eff destiny say yo I'm liking this then
that means more than me then my personal
real issues but again I don't have
issues I don't make it seem like I have
all these issues I'm just keeping it
even Qi want once we get more
information the layers get peel back and
we get deep dive more with the weapons
stuff and all that I just want to get
into the minutia but this is positive
man and they made me feel the power
fantasy again
feel you know that they're listening and
that's that's important what about you
for your closing statements on forsaken
uh I mean for me they gave it's kind of
one of those things and sometimes
Nintendo does this as well I'm not gonna
put up on the same discussion point mmm
sometimes they give you things you don't
ask for because you don't know what to
ask for
we all sink there's many things we asked
for and they gave us just about all that
stuff right then they came and gave us
the things we didn't think of with you
hey weapon slots is a three moving it up
is it for put it anywhere okay I mean
sorry
dirty connotations to that phrasing yeah
baby
no I don't come down but also I mean
you've got gamut like you want to you
want something that's gonna change the
game give us a new mode and that sounds
so much fun the raid with more bosses
than ever so you actually have a lengthy
encounter with pieces checkpoints got to
come back to so huge man and that was
for my boy that's for a dick man oh yeah
yeah I mean that's he loved taking King
and assets he always tell me say you
know the best bosses man you had boss
that's what they need and for them to
listen to him on that that's a big deal
so I know he's it is I think they did
little things for each little everybody
got their little complaints here the
answer as many of them as feasibly
possible no I mean I think like yeah i'm
in i'm absolutely in honestly can't wait
and this is one of those things that
changes up and be like okay if i want to
go go run a nightfall solo now like i
can no idea what i'm gonna run for like
oh doubt or anything like that if you're
gonna do like pv we haven't even this is
almost all PvE stuff right
we even even seen much in the crucible
world they're doing a new mode which may
be minor but i wouldn't imagine much but
new maps power level mattering trials
and iron banner come like just a lot of
little pieces here and there that all
are good pieces and there's more to come
so for me i mean
hats off i'm just sitting over here
gonna give an applause like i'm
definitely it's like
out of a initial reveal before even III
gets here I can't ask for much more
okay like I said I just want to deep
dive peel the layers back and let's get
into this thing man but uh great start
on this robbery action stream we shout
out to us for doing as much possible to
avoid spoilers yeah like I saw like one
thing and you probably did just you go
to Twitter just even go to direct
messages to you and I'm like dammit feed
quit shut up like I was let I just
wanted to avoid as much as possible it's
like one or two things and I think you
did too but I was pretty much completely
shocked so yeah shout out to us for
trying to go completely blind so well
you guys have nowhere to follow us I'm
gonna archive this on my youtube I'm
sure you will is the same and just
basically if you want to watch this
again
absolutely the stream I have that
private that's not for you guys they
know bunch of get it up that's not my
place to put that up that's there but go
watch that vitae go pause that look
through look for the little Easter eggs
pause it look for the screenshots like
those are the pieces between now and
what is next week I mean III you get to
go see gambit Nelson I'll be right let
me tell you finally I'll order a shadow
man I'll tell you right because he's
gonna be on it I'm gonna be on it I'm
gonna be at that Activision wolf I'm
gonna try to get as much content and
interviews as possible I'm gonna put try
to do hands-on now historically excuse
me
historically Bungie never lets you feel
I remember last year doing our destiny -
they usually don't let you film you know
the actual gameplay right then and there
I can get some interviews go away and
try to get some deep dives in that
respect - and also some impressions of
the mole cuz you know your boy won't
touch that game I'm gonna say yeah if
you can at least play it and give us
some thoughts on it yeah so that and
everything else going down there hey
it's like I mean honestly I play God of
War had a great time with it there's
still stuff I'm not done in that game
mm-hmm but I mean that's probably a 40
or 50 hour game for 60 bucks I'm gonna
get hundreds of hours out of the seven
like so I was like it's for me but hey I
was like I've had narrative with God of
War and went Detroit which is I gotta
talk about that one later that is insane
in a very different animal but I mean
getting back
my destiny love cannibals I'm height man
let my one caveat I want to know more
about the armor I've got a boy you know
so I want to know there maybe they just
aren't done so they're not showing but
that's my that's the other side light
weapon slots and I just got to know them
what what is happening with mods I think
that's my one weight so yeah see you
guys out there thank you for tuning in
is a long stream hello boy mm-hm
yeah yeah I'm here probably good your
long stream you know what he catches man
you know he's got stream up up she's
gonna go up in your ILP channel and yeah
this week I fly out to arm which ye 3 on
Friday morning so I'll be out there come
check out the iron more podcast channel
you know at all kinda like Twitter and
all that good stuff you know we're gonna
have try to get as much coverage as
possible and you know your boys gonna be
all over this destiny as much as I can
follow my Twitter if I'm on podcast
Twitter and yeah hopefully we get some
live reactions and stuff going on
why are we gonna floor and stuff no
absolutely so follow those guys Diane
Lord our Lord spoda cast inner circle
Network check both of those out you'll
keep up with everything they're doing on
III and this and right here guys me too
as well I know more destiny focus but
yeah we gonna be in the mix so you think
you guys on both ends of this for
everything and yeah like subscribe
follow all the goodies and stuff you
will you stay in tuned then we will see
you guys soon thanks for everything guys
no doubt please have a good